this is SEO foundations keyword research
and competitive intelligence at the end
of this lesson you should be able to
describe the importance of identifying
user intent when performing keyword
research list some basic methods for
performing keyword research explain the
difference between longtail queries and
short tail queries finally perform basic
competitive analysis on search queries
every search that you perform using a
search engine is based on keywords
people enter keywords to find useful
information as they have learned that
search provides answers fast while
selecting keywords there are two
important factors to consider keyword
traffic and competition keyword traffic
is the amount of search queries recorded
against a keyword competition is the
number of websites targeting that same
keyword while selecting a keyword you
might ideally want to pick those with
high traffic but it's not always the
right approach you also need to consider
the rate of competition a keyword with
high traffic and high competition may
take longer to get results
ideally find keywords with high traffic
but low competition for faster results
also there is no harm in picking
keywords with low traffic and low
competition in fact many businesses have
been built on finding these
opportunities user intent is paramount
with keyword research it is what drives
all of research queries on the Internet
you have people who search for something
like wh o and they could mean many
things by this it could mean the World
Health Organization they might also mean
the banned
they could also be looking for a
specific part of speech it depends on
the context of what they're searching
for it depends on how they capitalize it
it's important here to understand the
intent not necessarily the exact word
that they typed into the search engine
the intent makes all the difference so
let's look at this with a more realistic
example
and this is something I've taken from
clients because this happens all the
time in some parts of the United States
people use the word lawyer when they're
talking about someone who practices law
in other parts of the United States they
use the word attorney the difference in
these is very minimal except for when
you're focusing on user intent
specifically with search engine
optimization what's going to happen is
if you target the wrong version of this
word in the wrong part of the country
you won't get search traffic and you
won't be able to get many visitors so
this is what I spend a lot of my time
focusing on and that's figuring out what
do human beings in this context put into
the search engines when they're trying
to find a product or a service or an
answer more specifically my clients are
my products this is one of the most
important versions of this also is when
people search for buy versus free you'll
see this a lot in paid search they'll
work on user intent also but you need to
start optimizing for phrases that are
going to lead to your ultimate goal
which usually means conversions in many
cases that sales so what does that look
like well you want to rank for phrases
like buy cars buy coats or buy umbrellas
you don't actually care in most cases
when something is ranking for free
umbrellas or free cars are free advice
these aren't things that are going to be
helpful for you and actually build your
business intent is what you need to
spend your time learning and focusing on
now that we've talked about the
importance of keyword research let's
talk about a topic that is extremely
important and very closely related it's
called not provided now historically
search engines would give us all kinds
of data one of these important pieces of
data they would share with us was the
search volume and the search keywords
that people used when they found your
website so it looked like two things
first of all we have a phrase like
attorney or lawyer we could see how many
people were using it globally or how
many people were using it within a
specific region and this was very
important for optimizing our keywords
and optimizing our pages before we even
sent them out and before we could even
start test
against them we also had the data that
people used when they came to our
website so if they searched for attorney
or if they searched for a lawyer and
they made it to our website we'd be able
to see that in our analytics
unfortunately this has changed it first
started with Google and then moved on to
the rest of the search engines so today
when we look at our analytics we see
this phrase not provided because that
data is no longer available which is
unfortunate because we're no longer able
to make the data-driven decisions that
we once were based off of this keyword
data now that we've addressed the not
provided issue let's get back to the fun
part which is the research itself
there's a lot of different ways to do
this but I generally go into four
categories first off industry keywords
look at what phrases huming beings
actual people talk to the people in your
industry your customers people within
the industry and listen to them when
they describe what they need in terms of
products or services this can be just as
easy as walking around your office
talking to people or especially talking
to the sales team they know what people
want and they know the words that people
use so you could actually go out and
talk to people if you have access to
additional data online sometimes you can
get it from other sources these are
great places to look at what phrases
what words people use within your
industry and describe what it is that
you're trying to sell now the next area
is paid search you can find a lot of
keyword information with paid search you
can talk to your AdWords team or talk to
anyone is doing paid search for your
company they're going to have a lot of
access to search queries and lots of
phrases they can see the search phrases
that people are using see their ads and
go to the site so that's intelligence
that we can't get from the organic site
so hopefully they'll be able to work
with you and provide a list of things
that you might want to optimize for the
next one is a little less common but
certainly very valuable if you have it
and that's internal search most websites
at least in theory should have internal
search setup already the idea here is
you're looking at what your actual
visitor is typing into your own search
box on your own website and then you see
what keyword
phrases that they're looking for and
that can help you understand what people
need this is ideal because it's as
customized and is personalized to your
website as it can be so if you can use
the keyword data which actually shows up
in your analytics after you set it up
then you can use that to influence your
SEO research
the last one is competitor keywords in
an ideal world you could just ask your
competitors what are you ranking for but
in the real world nobody's going to tell
you so you have to go a roundabout way
of doing this now you could look at
other paid search tools and they'll show
you what your competitors are bidding on
and from those you can figure out their
strategy
I'm going to walk through one of my
favorite keyword research tools word
tracker in order to give you an idea of
how these tools work now as you can see
there's a basic dashboard for your
research there is the Google Keyword
database and the word tracker database
I'm going to use the Google Keyword
database now here I can put the keyword
that I want to research and then the
locations that I want to focus on now
this can be worldwide it can be a
specific country a city or region I'm
going to search the Google database
within the United States I want to see
how people search for the term digital
camera typically I start with the short
tail term as I went to see all the
different variations and options that
people search with now the words will
start populating and they typically load
from the words most searched to the
words least searched now of course just
the word camera has been searched on the
most and over 500 thousand times per
month that's in this volume column what
will tell you how many times about the
word has been searched on within that
time frame now these numbers are not
exact they're being pulled from a number
of different sources and so it doesn't
mean that there are exactly 500 thousand
searches per month on Google it's just a
good estimate now the next column is the
competition column you'll see this in a
lot of keyword research tools the higher
the number the higher the number of
competition that means the number of
websites that are all competing to rank
for this term based on using that term
in their optimization finally the right
column gives me a sense for how much
that word on average is costing
advertisers and paid search I can also
get a sense for the demand month by
month how many times two people search
for this word throughout the year it's
not popular all year long as you can see
here the word camera spikes and around
March and then again in November in
December within the United States all
these things are good to know now I want
to get a sense for how people search and
what is most important to them so here's
where I start building groups right away
what I start seeing are brands
Canon Nikon Olympus
bujji so i'll start developing a group
of brand names and then features what
are people looking for in their cameras
I see two right here that are very
interesting and that is underwater
camera and waterproof camera two very
important features I'll start a list for
that as well
then types what are some other things
people are searching for I see cheap
35-millimeter kids used compact all
different words that people are using to
describe the type of camera they want
these are the words you want to make a
list for and group together especially
as you see them appear again and again I
also find places like best place to buy
or buy online or where to buy keep those
in mind put those in another list and
finally information suggests comparison
reviews best cameras top rated that's
what I'm looking for
now when I start organizing these groups
and I want to create a project let's go
back to features like my underwater
camera and waterproof camera I'll check
those that way I can add them to my
project I can hit save and they're added
to my water camera list now I can also
export anything that I have selected and
I can copy that to the clipboard and
then add that to a spreadsheet through
the spreadsheet it will export all of
the volume data the competitive data and
I can go through and work through it
different ways and really dig into the
words this has been a quick overview of
word tracker keyword research tool now
let's dig in a little further on how to
use a keyword research tool you see it's
much deeper than simply making a list of
keywords too many people attempt to do
SEO and all they have is a list with a
few keywords and that's not going to get
you far
keyword research doesn't just tell you
the words people use you can find intent
what they really want what's important
preferences opinions and ideas
you also see what they need and how they
express it now part of SEO is writing
articles blog posts social posts but how
will you know what to write about if you
don't know what people really need so
this is where you dig in the amount of
time you spend in keyword research will
be greatly rewarded the better you
understand the searchers the better
you'll deliver to them what they want
and I break this down in four ways first
I look for the brand name then I look to
see what words people have associated
with it I'm I find that there are other
brands with similar names I may also
find issues if people are associating
negative words or ideas to the brand
that shows that there might be some work
to be done to be rebuild trust also I
want to connect popular brand searches
to the destination pages which page
ranks for those brand terms and also are
they my pages I want to know if someone
else is ranking for any of my branded
terms or if better pages can be ranking
on my own site for my own brand second
look for the related concepts of the
keyword then start grouping and
categorizing larger groups to smaller
groups find as many different
associations with the keyword and then
categorize them you can group them by
sales cycle if you can identify words
that are used early and words used as
people move closer to their decision the
groups would each show a different
intent of the searcher third look for
specific indicators of time location or
features these are words or related
words that may indicate a city a region
or a location also any time frames
seasonality or trends to the words
throughout the year and then any
associated dates or events that people
use and features features that are
specific to your product your business
your industry as those obviously are
important if they make it into the key
word now finally I want to identify the
specific questions or needs that people
have if they're actually asking a
question that's great more words gives
me more context and I want to know what
they want how they express that need in
words and
those needs these steps will not only
help you in crafting good SEO but also
in developing content which will enable
you to communicate effectively to the
site visitor and understand the context
of the market when you're looking at
your organic search queries it's easiest
to divide all of your search queries up
into two broad categories these
categories are what we call short tail
and long tail so what does that mean the
first one is short tail short tail is
going to be the short frequently
searched for broad keywords now more
often than not this is branded keywords
what's the name of your company or key
products again these are very very short
keywords one or two words people search
for them all the time
and especially with your brand they will
come up frequently but also they're very
very broad they typically are one or two
words that indicate an entire industry
not using any other descriptive words
it's just the simplest way of explaining
a product or a service within a large
industry now the long tail is exactly
the opposite this is what's important
the long tail is going to make up the
vast majority of your traffic the reason
being that well people are going to
mostly search for very broad terms
utilizing multiple words you see most
people are going to be very descriptive
when they are using words to search for
something specific typically they're
closer to buying or making a decision so
they tend to add more attributes to
their search terms color attributes
product numbers locations things like
that long tail and short tail is kind of
hard to define from a quantitative
perspective but generally speaking when
you have more than three words it's
going to be longtail if you have one or
two words that's typically a short tail
let's cover the short tail a little bit
further now there are pros and cons to
try to rank for short tail words now the
biggest Pro the biggest good of a short
tail word is that it's typically a very
general word if it's your branded term
you may already rank for it but short
tail keywords are so general and they
apply to such a large
industry and maybe even across different
industries they became very difficult to
rank for so it takes a very large budget
to go after some of these very short
tail terms now here's an example many
people in the automotive industry would
love to rank number one for the word
cars however the word is so broad that
it doesn't apply to any one specific
someone might only sell new cars or old
cars or small cars large expensive cheap
and we haven't even gotten into the
brands now you see we need these
additional words to help provide
guidance otherwise we don't know what is
meant by this single word cars as I said
most in the automotive industry would
love to have that ranking but that's not
what people need people might search for
cars and realize how big that is and
then start using additional words to
drill down now if I'm selling cars
obviously I'd like that but someone's
searching at that level is it going to
be relevant especially if I'm in a
specific location I only offer a certain
type of car I have additional services
or brands you see first of all start
optimizing for your business and in your
location and you'll naturally grow in
relevance now if it's in your strategy
to go after short tail terms be prepared
to work hard and be prepared to spend a
lot of money it's not going to be cheap
to accomplish and it will take a long
while to happen especially if you are
just starting out with a new website now
that we've talked about the short tail
let me explain why the long tail is so
amazing you see the long tail keyword
phrases are more descriptive and more
targeted which is great because it means
that if someone comes in on one of those
phrases they're much more likely to
convert these are really wonderful
phrases especially when you're just
starting out it's much easier to be the
only person who's trying to rank for one
specific phrase if it's extremely long
descriptive and targeted it's easier
than trying to rank for one term that
the whole world is competing for so when
you're just starting out with search
engine optimization you want to
have a realistic expectation you should
be focusing initially on the long tail
with longer term goals of the short tail
but start there your clients and you may
like this because it means a smaller
budget long tail results happen very
quickly as there's much less competition
and it's much easier to establish
initial rankings for these phrases now
analyzing competition is the easiest and
early activity that an SEO can undertake
it comprises checking the keywords that
the competition ranks for and studying
their content is this the content that
you eventually want to rank for this
information is useful in building your
content and keyword phrases there are
four areas that you can look at while
performing competitive analysis the
first is identifying competition that
may include websites such as Wikipedia
or Directory Sites an SEO must know who
the competition is you will know the
challenges and the resources required to
rank for competitive terms
the next is taking a realistic
perspective based on the competition how
difficult will it be to rank for a given
term
if your competition is a gigantic
international corporation that has the
keyword you want in its domain name it
will take years to rank well in the
keyword search now this is indicative
that you might not want to waste time
trying to rank for this keyword but look
to your efforts elsewhere the next one
is studying the content that's powering
the success of competitors
observe the content format of blog posts
videos and images so that your content
may be similar for ranking purposes
however it's vitally important to
remember this just because a competitor
has words in their strategy and they are
ranking well for those words it does not
necessarily mean that those words are
bringing them business when you evaluate
competitors you're only evaluating half
of the picture the other half is their
analytics and their sales data you can
only see what they advertise not what
makes them money or brings them business
so be careful of the thinking that
because a competitor uses certain words
that they're also successful in that use
there's not a direct correlation finally
analyze user experience check why people
are linking to some content what their
incentives are why Google has ranked
certain content for a certain keyword
and so on check why people are linking
to some content what their incentives
are why Google has ranked certain
content for a certain keyword so on
competitive analysis can get highly
technical so instead of going extremely
deep into that I want to show you the
general ideas and the metrics that I
look for when I'm doing this the first
one is the domain name of my competitors
I want to look at this from a few
different angles in terms of what I'm
looking for I want to see how
established that brand is both online
and offline does the domain name contain
keywords that I'm trying to rank for and
if I'm trying to rank for the term let's
say Wikipedia and you notice there's
another website that happens to be
called Wikipedia you're not gonna be
able to compete with that so I'm just
giving that as an example you want to
look at how competitive that is and how
much is the domain name going to have an
effect now the next one is domain
Authority and this is slightly different
because it's an actual metric it's
something that you can look up online
what this will tell you is what the link
profile of that domain looks like does
it have a lot of links are those links
coming from trusted sources are those
links coming from trusted sources that
are going to be hard to compete with all
these things are important for
evaluating how strong
of a competitor this is already the next
one is the number of indexed pages of
the competitors this will tell you how
much the search engines like this domain
if the search engines like this domain
and that website has a lot of pages it's
going to be extremely difficult so
you'll be able to see this score with
most SEO management software the last
thing to look at is paid search terms
look at what ads are around the keyword
when I search in the search engine it's
going to tell you what companies care
about that keyword and are targeting it
in their paid search campaigns if
they're spending money on it it's an
important metric to look at and we can
look at this and say okay I've searched
for the generic term and I see five
companies that have paid money to buy
these ads I'm going to add that keyword
to my competitive list and I'm going to
go through the first four and see how
much of a threat they are so I want to
make it clear that there are lots and
lots of different metrics that you can
look at but these are the four places to
start one of the biggest benefits of SEO
is the foundational elements equally
apply to other potential markets while
the keywords that you target will change
somewhat for business-to-business and
business-to-consumer marketing the
high-level strategy that you use with
SEO will remain exactly the same
your best execution of SEO will require
following best practices of keyword
targeting and on-page optimization so
that your urls and products will show up
in the search engines when potential
buyers look for your product now
regardless of your niche the SEO best
practices remain the same imagine you
have a business-to-business oriented
business you're developing leads online
and you have a Salesforce now your
Salesforce might be calling potential
customers meeting with prospective
buyers and other businesses
now even though your goals in your sales
cycle would be very different than a
small business to consumer business the
SEO is the same you're following best
practices keyword targeting on-page
optimization and you'll be targeting
something that is specific to your
business
either way you accomplish results by
producing high-quality well optimized
information that answers people's
questions when you develop great content
that informs educates and entertains
you'll naturally develop links when
people like your content and share it
with others key takeaways from this
section user intent is the driver of
word choice and search demand and it is
the foundation of a strong SEO strategy
some basic methods for performing
keyword research include analyzing
industry keywords paid search campaigns
internal Site Search and competitor
keywords short tail keywords are
typically short have high search volume
but broad intent long tail keywords are
typically long have lower search volume
and have specific intent
[Music]